[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best bi wise fashion tips makeup acts
and so much more we are sure you're
going to love it and be sure to let us
know what you think in the comment
section we see the logos of famous
companies everywhere we go these days
sometimes it can be easy to forget that
they are there but some clever artists
have reimagined them they've taken these
everyday graphics then turn them into
some pretty dangerous weapons today we
are going to take a look at some of them
make sure to watch all the way through
to see how the classic Nike logo became
sinister hola did you hear about our
latest addition to our family their
richest espanol is the perfect place for
all you native Spanish speakers out
there don't speak Spanish no problem
come on over this is the perfect place
to practice amazing facts interesting
people and the funny pictures those
ammos ahi
here are five famous logos reimagined as
dangerous weapons Facebook probe on
Facebook has been one of the most
successful companies who have been
founded in the 21st century it's helped
to take the internet and make it an
integral part of people's lives pretty
much every company artist musician and
person or their own Facebook page tech
there's even a chance that you may well
have discovered this video through the
site and it's a big part of our lives
the one artist here
city's Tom Dahl has taken the ubiquitous
F logo and given it a dark and dangerous
twist he turned it into a pretty
intimidating looking crowbar at the risk
of making the bad pun we really don't
think that you don't like this if he's
also a wielding it sorry
and being a crowbar there's other
criminal activity one could use it for
but we'd hope that you would as we said
Facebook uses massive what founder Mark
Zuckerberg started as a way to keep his
classmates at Harvard University in
touch has become a gigantic business
with more than 1 billion users it's also
been the dominant form of social media
for some while now the likes of my face
and Bebo have declined while FB has
changed adapted and flourish to be
honest we can't imagine a world without
it but what's your favorite social media
site why not let us know by leaving a
comment we get kind of nostalgic for our
old live journal sometime
mcDonald's brass muffled the McDonald's
golden arches is one of the most iconic
logos in all of advertising you can see
them all over the world and when you do
you'll know the restaurant has at least
one thing you'll want for one artist
turned a welcoming logo into something a
bit more disturbing easier two
distinctive curves of the M sign to
become a pair of brass knuckles this
weapon is especially spine-chilling as
it can be used subtly if you were to be
hit with a knuckle duster there's a good
chance you'd have no idea before it was
way too late to do anything about it
well at least these are big enough you'd
be able to get away or at least call the
authorities
it's talking of McDonald's did you know
that it's been a long time since it was
owned by anyone called McDonald's in
1954 American businessman Ray Kroc
visited a restaurant in San Bernardino
California run by dick and Max McDonald
who like their burgers and their simple
menu and six years later he bought the
rights to the name since then the firm
has become a worldwide success it
operates in more than 100 countries and
has more than 36,000 franchise
restaurants that's an awful lot of
places where the golden arches stands
ready to welcome people to break rocks
vision of quality service cleanliness
and value
mercedes-benz throwing star the
mercedes-benz star logo is usually a
sign of a high five high cost kind of
car it's not the sort of thing you'd
expect to get involved in some kind of
horrific street fight but but again an
advantage if you can but you can take
the star out of the laurel wreath that
surrounds it and throw it at someone it
is do quite a lot of sandwich we think
it's good that this mercedes-benz ninja
throwing star is this a work of art we
wouldn't like one hurtling to us after
being thrown then again we wouldn't like
to see what hurtling out as well as
being driven Mercedes fans is probably
got the longest history of car company
in the world Provenge
invented the world's first combustion
engine in Germany in 1879 in the city of
Mannheim and developed the world's first
car Saban's
patent Motorwagen but it was in 1925
after the Benz / merged with Daimler
that the company's laurel wreath that
combines with Tyler's three-pointed star
the star has three points to symbolize
where time was engines could go slammed
water and air have you wondered where
the Mercedes part of the name came from
Daimler's designer was an Austrian
called emo jelly net when we designed a
racing car in 1902 he named it after his
daughter Mercedes other cars have been
given people's names such as the Skoda
Fabia or as a Ford Edge phone but we
think the original is still the best
literal Google bomb when you think of
the Internet you think of trying to find
what you want to look for and that
usually means the search engine and for
most people that means Google the
company has become one of the largest
websites on the Internet
we wouldn't be surprised if you did
already today you might have even found
the same alone there but imagine the
power of Google ozonated to evolve that
is what art collected for real big
turning the recognizable colors and
fonts into a weapon of mass destruction
did you know that there's a thing called
a Google bomb though it's when someone
tries to create links to a search term
to put an unexpected result at the top
of the Google search listing usually
this is done for humorous or satirical
purposes also did you know that Google
hasn't always been called people when
founders Sergey Brin and Larry Page
first created a search engine back in
1995 it was called backrub but they
changed the name and quickly became the
most popular way to find stuff online as
time has gone on the company has become
one of the biggest in Silicon Valley
photos YouTube it makes the Android
operating system and launched its own
brand of phones in 2016 so you could be
watching something on a Google phone
using Google software on a Google owned
site which you found through Google the
90s book becomes a dangerous place
Nike is one of the biggest sportswear
companies in the
famous for its tracksuits and it's air
Brandis trainers the firm based in
Oregon USA was rated as being worth
fifteen point nine billion dollars in
September 2017 that's an awful lot of
leisure where it was also the official
kick provider for basketballs NBA in
2017 in one of many high-profile deals
but for one artist it was the company's
famous swoosh logo that provided a
pretty strange but pretty cool
inspiration New Yorker Tom calls social
eise's interning everyday objects into
something different than usual and
looking at the source we came up with
the idea of turning it into exact
luckily this object is only an artwork
not a real weapon that's evidently a
good thing because it does appear to be
pretty dangerous-looking when you first
see it the curve of the logo must become
a double appointment wave pretty nasty
but pretty clever all at the same time
you know that Nike is named after the
Greek goddess of
she was often portrayed as a winged
figure and it could be the swoosh isn't
just a tick making reference to the
firm's
just do it motto it might also be a
stylized weight oh and the company is
pronounced 219 in the United States that
night outside of it what other things
could you put a logo design to you guys
let us know in the color and that's bad
for our five famous logos reimagined as
dangerous weapons if you liked it you
might want to check out ten unbelievable
animals that save people drive thanks
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]